And we discussed many issues, but one of
the most I think perhaps misunderstood
uh areas of the practices and the
worship of uh Muslims during the month
of Ramadan is etikaf. Could you firstly
explain the termikaf?
And could you also as uh by way of
confirming for the Muslims out there
whether they should be doing this or not
um is it compulsory for all Muslims to
do it? Alhamdulillah.
The word
is derived from the Arabic root word
which means to adhere, to cling, to
stick. It means to keep
and it means to engage or devote
something to another thing
which may be good or bad.
And it's mentioned in the Quran in surah
amyia chapter number 21 verse number 52
when Abraham
he speaks to his father and to his
people saying that the images which you
devote
those who do idol worship etc. He's
saying that the image which you devote
and the word uses which you so devotly
attached to which you're clinging to it
here it's used in the wrong sense in the
negative sense there are also vers in
the Quran which speak the positive sense
in surah bakar chapter 2 verse 125 surah
bakar chap 2 verse 187 according to
the word
means to fully attach oneself to
something.
It means when someone habitates the
mosque and he worships in it. In the
Islamic Sharia, the word eth means to
engage and retreat in the mosque and to
stay in the mosque seeking nearness to
Allah subhana wa t'ala and seeking his
reward.
As far as the ruling of ethical is
concerned, whether it's compulsory or it
is a sunnah, ethikaf is generally a
sunnah. It's not compulsory. It only
becomes compulsory in certain cases if
someone makes a vow to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala that he will do if his wish is
fulfilled. For example, someone will say
that I will do ethika for two days if my
sick relative is cured or I may do
ethika for three days if I pass in the
examination. So if someone vows to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala for the fulfillment
of his desire then ethikaf is
compulsory. Whatever the person has
vowed he has to fulfill it. Otherwise
the sunnah but it is a sunnah moa a very
highly recommended sunnah
as it's mentioned in the hadith
of sai bkari volume number 8 in the book
of oaths and vows had number 6696
where the messenger of Allah subhanaa
tala said that anyone who promises
to obey Allah subhanana wa ta'ala he
should obey him and anyone who promises
disobedience to Allah subhana wa t'ala
he should not disobey him
and there's a hadith
may Allah be pleased with him mentioned
in say Bkari volume number 8 in the book
of oaths and vows had number 6697
may Allah be pleased with him he says to
the messenger of Allah subhanaa tala
that I had vowed in the days of
ignorance before he embraced Islam that
he will do ethikah for one night in
mazjid haram. So the prophet said that
fulfill your vow because the wa was good
obeying Allah subhanaa tala the prophets
is fulfilled
and there are various verses in the
Quran we speak about Allah says in surah
bakar chapter number two verse number
125 he tells to Ibraimisam and to isam
that oh Abraham and is may peace be upon
them you sanctify
the of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala the
house of Allah subhanana wa tala because
people circumambulate around the cabba
and they stay they do ethikaf they
retreat in the mosque and some of the
believers they bow and they prostrate
while worshiping Allah subhanaa tala
here the word ethic of retreat is used
it's further mentioned in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 187 that
do not associate with your wives when
you retreat in the mosque when you do in
the mosque and there are several talking
including say bkari volume number three
in the book of hadith number 2026
Aisha may Allah be pleased with her who
was the wife of the prophet she said
that the prophet used to do ethikah for
the last 10 days in the month of Ramadan
and after he died the wives of the
prophet used to continue that practice
so ethikov
Unless it's compulsory otherwise
generally it's a sunnah but highly
recommended sunnah.